so I really went back and forth about whether
to even do this story today about how
still is no connection between undocumented
immigrants and criminality.
Because on the one hand we've already covered
this story.
It's sort of obvious that this is the case,
but there are still so many people who believe
deeply believe that undocumented immigrants
are more likely to commit crimes in the United
States.
So ultimately I made the case that it is worth
debunking once again.
And before I even tell you about the new report,
let's just remind ourselves of some of the
obvious realities coming to the United States.
Illegally is illegal.
Uh, it can be a misdemeanor or a civil infraction
depending on whether you've overstayed a visa
or a crossing the border without permission.
That's not what's at issue here.
Okay?
What does that issue here is whether undocumented
immigrants do or do not commit more crime
than native born Americans or more crime than
legal immigrants to the United States.
And we hear a lot of specific anecdotes from
Donald Trump and and right wingers who have
propagandized around this, about crimes committed
by undocumented immigrants.
And of course in a country this big, there
are examples of everything, but this is important
because our policy towards immigration would
be different depending on whether or not undocumented
immigrants actually are more likely to commit
violent crime and property crime in the United
States.
But this is pretty obvious.
Undocumented immigrants know that they are
undocumented.
They know that if they get into trouble with
the authorities, if they come to the attention
of law enforcement, not only it could they
suffer the penalties for the crime that they
commit, but they could be deported.
They could get in trouble for being undocumented.
So why would a group that knows they have
an extra incentive to stay off the radar of
law enforcement?
Why would they commit crimes at a higher rate
than native born Americans and legal immigrants
and attract the attention of law enforcement?
Yes, we know that poverty and crime are connected.
Many undocumented immigrants are poor, but
the research has shown for a long time that
undocumented immigrants aren't more likely
to be violent criminals.
And yet again, we have a new study with pew
data.
Pew Research Center data analyzed by the Marshall
Project with tells us that undocumented immigrants
don't increase crime rates, whether or not
undocumented immigration to a metro area increased.
The crime rates have continued to slowly decline
more or less equally.
And in fact, there are many areas with more
undocumented immigration that have had even
larger decreases in crime even though it's
by a small amount and maybe not statistically
significant.
Now this is not to argue that we shouldn't
deal with undocumented immigration, which
is still a crime, right?
Although it's only a civil infraction or a
misdemeanor.
Again, depending on whether you're talking
about an overstayed a visa or crossing the
border without permission, but we cannot allow
this discussion to be framed as we have a
crisis of violent undocumented immigrants
in the United States because we don't, and
this is actually the epitome of how the Republican
Party often very successfully influences public
opinion.
The principal is they take an anecdote and
they exploited to make people scared or angry
and to eventually support bad policy policy.
That doesn't actually make sense.
So let me do an analogy.
A first to abortion.
They come out, they say extreme late term
abortions have to be stopped.
Democrats are killing babies.
This is horrible.
When you look at it, you realize, wait a second,
extreme late term abortion is really rare.
And when it's something that takes place,
the baby often is going to die anyway within
days or weeks of, of coming out of the uterus.
And it more becomes a question of the life
of the mother.
It becomes a question of how soon is this
fetus going to be determined?
Non-Viable.
But Republicans use the straw man of the post
birth abortion and all of these crazy things
to justify trying to ban abortion altogether.
This is the same thing going on with, uh,
with undocumented immigration.
An illegal as they like to say, killed this
person.
Well, that's a crime.
It's a tragedy.
It's horrifying.
Okay.
I would not even think of minimizing the horrible
nature of that.
But the real discussion around undocumented
immigration is, is not actually about crime.
It's about economics.
It's about culture, it's about geopolitics.
It's about diplomacy and foreign relations
and foreign policy.
That's the real conversation around undocumented
immigration.
And the problem is that if you actually have
the conversation on those terms instead of
about these crimes that Donald Trump and others
like to point to, um, the, the outcome, the
right path forward becomes one that the American
right simply doesn't want.
It becomes one of working to minimize the,
uh, circumstances in the source countries
of undocumented immigration that make people
want to come here to begin with.
It becomes an issue of dealing with the economic
conditions and the large corporations that
are actually a big driver for that undocumented
immigration because they are employing undocumented
immigrants.
If you actually deal with undocumented immigration
as an economic, cultural and geopolitical
issue, you can't justify the policies that
Republicans want, which is why they have to
couch it in these terms of dangerous brown
people coming over the border.
Yet another study tells us it's absolutely
ridiculous.